This small icon means participation.
This is a great system in Android.
You can create action_send intent yourself,
But better use ShareCompat and share text using
Only one order.
I mean like - I will explain what is necessary
To share content correctly with other apps,
As well as receiving content.
What types of content?
We've seen the text, but what about HTML-formatted text
Files and images, is anything like this possible?
Yes, possible.
So let's do it.
Let's share some texts.
ShareCompat does the hard work of building intent.
We just make sure you set the MIME type.
The app filters the content type
Who can receive it.
Then we call startActivity .
And we surround it with resolveActivity .
This prevents the activity from finding exceptions to situations
They do not already have any apps
You can handle what we share.
Caution is better than remorse.
But that was very easy.
We implement HTML text - as an e-mail message.
Well, there is not much to do.
HTML text uses setHtmlText .
That's logical.
Add topic and we can add address fields to "
And a copy to a Bcc and multiple Bcc.
It applies only to mail applications, but it is OK.
The receiving applications can ignore it if desired.
Just provide all you have.
But talk about the sender side,
Without talking about the future side,
Like talking about peanut butter without mention
Jelly candy, or something like that.
Future activity will need an intent filter
With the appropriate MIME type.
We will note that we have added the category.DEFAULT.
We will not get any of the implicit intent mechanisms to startActivity
Which we created without it.
category.BROWSABLE is what allows for sites
Share directly within the app.
Then, whether you use the SharedCompat sender or not,
You can use the intentReader to extract
The information you need.
But the text, whether coordinated or not, is somewhat primitive.
Let's move on to the fun part - sharing an image, for example.
Now we are approaching our goal.
Well, if setStream is new.
Except where do we get uriToImage ?
Here comes the interesting part.
You may think this can be the path of the file that performs the image itself.
This is really a bad idea.
This means that the file must be written in an accessible location
From other applications, which may require
WRITE_STORAGE permission, and the future application will need
Sure to READ_STORAGE permission.
With Android Marshmallow 6.0,
These are serious permissions
Request during run-time.
Do not be such applications.
Instead, we have a full training document
Sharing files correctly does not require any permission
Store using FileProvider.
Check out the publications and documents on our blog to learn how to set up everything first.
So how does our code look now?
We have used getUriForFile for the file provider
For a URI that can be shared and suitable for scrolling to another application.
Wonderful.
We can even get a way to select the type automatically
Of the file.
Inside, this so-called method is used
With URI-based permissions.
The application gives the sender permission
For only one URI.
We grant permission to call setData through a URI,
Then add FLAG_GRANT_READ_URI_PERMISSION.
That's all.
Now the future side can use getContentResolver
openInputStream to get the image.
If we know how to share texts and files with other applications,
As well as receiving these files, all this
Without serious permissions.
I hope this helps you to cooperate with others
And better apps.